[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATTHEW SPELLBERG: I knew
actually that I wanted to
teach in a prison before I
came to graduate school.
And I picked Princeton in part
because I knew that there was
a prison teaching
program here.
BETH STROUD: The students
are incredible.
They are the most motivated
students I've ever met.
ROSS LERNER: There are some
people who are drawn to it for
reasons that have mostly
to do with activism.
And then there are people who
are drawn to it mostly because
they identify as educators.
MARCUS JOHNSON: And we got the
question, they're like, well,
we know you're paid.
We're like, actually
we're not.
And so we got a battery of
questions like, well, do they
pay for your gas?
Do they pay for your food?
We're like no.
We actually want to do this.
GILLIAN KNAPP: It's
pure teaching.
It's chalk.
It's waving your hands.
It's talking to people.
It's doing your calculations,
your essays, your corrections
in pencil and paper.
REGINALD MURPH: I became
involved in the teaching
initiative because there
was a flyer in the
hallway of the prison.
I was walking.
And I remember seeing it.
And I'm like, naw.
How good could college
classes be in prison?
And I was with my cell mate.
And he was telling, he's like,
maybe you should just try it.
Just do it.
You get out of the cell
a little more.
I'm like, all right.
I'll try it.
And I'll do it.
And I did a public speaking
class, which I loved.
And it was a really
good class.
And then I started taking
more and more.
SANDRA SUSSMAN: Our students
are just incredible, really
motivated, passionate about
learning and about turning
their lives around through
education.
MARCUS JOHNSON: I would say that
I am a role model, and
particularly as a black male in
a prison population that is
over represented in
African Americans.
ROSS LERNER: Genuinely you are
pushed to be a better teacher,
because you'll really be called
out if you're not being
a good teacher in
this context.
BETH STROUD: I've heard so many
of them say that they
wish they had applied themselves
more in middle
school, and high school, when
they have the opportunity, and
how happy they are despite where
they are to have that
opportunity to have a second
chance at that opportunity to
take learning seriously.
REGINALD MURPH: If I had to
speak to an inmate that was
kind of hesitant about going
to school, I guess I would
advise him just take a class,
see where he's at.
But if he wants it, and he does
see a future for himself,
then he definitely pursue it.
Because you can't
lose nothing.
It doesn't hurt to try.
And also, I mean, it's real.
It's a real thing.
I was happy when I took
the Princeton classes.
What makes a great great is
not the goals that the
accomplish but the obstacles
they overcome to accomplish
those goals.
[MUSIC PLAYING]